hello and welcome to the podcast
it's me hans kim arena comic ufc
courtside
viewer
coming at you live
um
i am
looking for some headphones
and here we go here's the board
uh my hair is getting caught in the
green screen
but i guess i don't really need
headphones you know it kind of takes
away from the whole experience
um but
reuben is already disconnected
he's reconnected
hopefully he'll be here for the game
here in present and aware and conscious
but i don't have to play katan i can do
anything
and everything that my heart desires
a lot of different things on my mind
right now
i'm trying to pull up the
comments
um
i don't know how to do it
he's placed okay so i'm next
i'm trying to figure out how to get the
comments up and running
uh let's put this here
youtube
it says 12 dots a lot of brick
this has 12 dots or 13 whatever 13 dots
it's diverse
this has not 13 this is 12 dots and
that's the spot he chose
interesting choice
i'm going to this spot for now
this spot has a lot of brick
let's see what the brick port looks like
sweet
not my favorite i'm going with this one
because of the diversity and then 13
dots
very rarely will you get 13 dots so i
will take advantage of it unlike orange
who forgot to or didn't or
just planted something
i could go here this would be a good
spot this has seven
dots this has five this is a port and
five
it says eight dots
i like this one gives me more options
and how are you guys doing um
i'm having a good time
i don't know how to pull up the comments
some [ __ ]
got rearranged
um
let me google it
how how to
comment
panel
obs
add stream chat to obs
um
[Music]
i wish you guys could help me but i
can't see your comments
um but i feel like it should be easy
view
uh
chat
there we go
hello wow
i'm glad i went through all that effort
so you guys can tell me hello well uh so
this is a green screen i bought for my
house for my
room
and i'm using the canon
and not my rebel
canon rebel
my little tripod
playing a little catanimals
having a good time relaxing
uh i'm i met a woman recently and i've
been spending a lot of time with her i'm
sorry i haven't spent a lot of time with
you guys and then before that
i was
well again he says
wow
like an owen will wilson wow
i really would like my headphones so i
can see if i sound [ __ ] but
i don't think it's gonna happen
i cannot find it
i hope i didn't lose it i think i had it
maybe i was
right here
whatever i might be
able to
buy new headphones with some money i got
from being an arena comic
we're going to comic-con skim here ufc
ringside
uh
[Music]
sitter
hans kim here
um
why are you up so late
i was just with a beautiful lady having
a good time with her
that's probably why i'm up so late
now ninja fry is gonna go again
but uh you know we can get a lot of
different backgrounds up here
let me
try to
how was the arena the arena was amazing
it was packed full of people
it was uh
not in the round
[Music]
and it was
not in the round it was
unrounded
um
it was a flat
area
and then the sides and then you know
europe over
over in the other area you know you know
how arenas work
um
but it was a good show i had a good time
it was crazy you know
all those people
all that
humanity
looking at you
you know making observations about you
trying not to
be
have them be unimpressed but i mean i
met a couple people after the show and
they weren't super complimentary some of
them were
some some of them were super
complimentary
but some of them weren't and that's how
i know i didn't have a good set or i
didn't have as good a set as i wanted to
because if i had a good set i could have
tricked them into thinking i was super
funny
and i don't know if i did it as well as
i wanted to
i need brick and wheat
wheat is here brick is here
so it's going to be tricky to get both
this has seven nine dots no wheat
and if i'm going to play a no wheat game
i'm gonna need a [ __ ] port
this spot has
five wheat
this spot has
more
yeah it's going to be tricky to find
a way to make this work
um i could forgo wheat or brick but i
need both of them to build a settlement
i need wheat
to
build a city so i might prioritize wheat
but there's not very lot of dots this
one is seven dots
and it's close to my original
this one has seven nine dots
is it worth foregoing
sona's
five nine dots as well and a wheat only
two wheat over there
hmm and if i build here i'm just gonna
have to forgo brick
for a long time
the thing about brick is you need it to
build roads so i could be having a
roadless game
um
i could go here
i could get this
a lot of wood
hmm
it's a tricky one
i could build here
and get a lot of
wheat
and from the wheat port
that's only three
wheat
so i'm not really
favoring that
i think what i'll do is i'll put it here
and then i'll try to
get some wheat from
somewhere else
uh is there a sheet port okay well it's
whatever
so i'm gonna build a lot of roads
i don't know how i'm gonna get wheat
but i'm gonna get a lot of resources so
that's good
yeah this is seven
uh yeah that's a valuable spot
it's cheap and wood damn this guy got
good spots
um
fortunately i didn't need any sheep or
wood
so this is just a game i'm playing
i'll put it here [ __ ] over orange
because i'm jealous
because i'm a hater
um and then i'll build a road
to the port or here
which one do you think i should do
uh here i'll get more wheat here i'll
get the port i'm gonna get more wheat
anyways this is very boring to some
people i found that i can play online so
that's cool
how is arena you sound great thanks man
like
physically or like in terms of my audio
setup how's your new material coming
along
i'm trying
okay i'm trying no i'm trying
um i'm trying to write i'm trying to
you know
be a writer and all that where are some
good places to stay in a van around
austin
well a good place to stay around austin
is creek field google it it's right by
the river it's a park and it's a very
long driveway
which is annoying because you need a car
to get there but good because a lot less
people a lot fewer people go there
oh [ __ ] i didn't end my turn
it's a big no-no
anyways
uh creek field it's like a softball
field it's like giant lawns and they
have three little parking lots it's a
crazy
thing like you could build like a whole
city inside that footprint but it's just
abandoned i would drive there and i
would see deer i would see armadillos
it's like
abandoned it's like there's so many
um
oh [ __ ] he got the robber he's gonna
[ __ ] me
so many uh wildlife there
yep he [ __ ] me took my brick and
covered my brick so now i want to break
until this [ __ ] moved
oh [ __ ] blue's trying to [ __ ] me
oh my god why wouldn't you just build
here
what does he need
he needs this wheat he doesn't need this
wheat i need this sweet
[ __ ] why is blue trying to [ __ ] me like
this
so rude
god damn and how is he getting so many
[ __ ] resources he already has
six i might be [ __ ] this game
tan you lose and you lose for two hours
eventually seeing your demise but maybe
it could happen
um
i'm so delirious with exhaustion i would
say go to sleep i'm doing fine if you
can tell i'm at the peak of my game
i'm looking for my headphones
can't find them it's fine i'm on a green
screen right now
um
i don't know
let me see
filters
let me uh show you
green screen
you can see the little ripples i would
like to get rid of that
eventually
um oops now i gotta fix it
okay i'm fine with the chair being a
little grainy
um
yeah i mean
blue's really being a [ __ ] right now
he wants to trade oh he [ __ ] me
what a [ __ ] it really didn't
change anything about him at all
like this
this spot and this spot is the same
thing
but i guess he just wants to [ __ ] me
i mean this says rock which is more
valuable but he wants wheat apparently
oh wait he doesn't have any wheat
okay
maybe i should have tried
trading
oh [ __ ]
this is going to be hard
i could try to get this rock part
but blue really [ __ ] me and it's not
something i will forgive or forget
he's only trading with blue for this
red and blue are in an alliance
that's annoying
interesting
i guess we're all wheat
starved
we all need wheat
this [ __ ]
i need to move that robber too
damn blue's really making me look like a
fool in front of everyone right now
um
yeah i like katan because i can play
like this oh
[ __ ]
dude
this is not a good game
i hate myself i hate myself i hate
myself
yeah what are you gonna do
i don't need as many
okay at least i got to move this i'm
gonna try to [ __ ] blue
blue you're going down i would like
brick
[ __ ]
okay
i'm gonna get wheat
oh i should have tried to trade
anyways whatever
blue
stick is rock that doesn't do anything
for him
um
okay i got a sheep that's good
um
how's your new material coming along i'm
trying this that's what this is for i'm
trying to come up with new material or
some good place to stay in a van oh yeah
creek field a softball field with a
giant parking lot huge ass place
it's a beautiful place
once there was a cop there just
sitting
facing the wrong way
down the street
and he was just staring at me and then i
tried to park there and he followed me
around
creek field and i left because he was
he was menacing me
and that's what cops do they're like oh
you're trying to do something legal but
something that i don't approve of or
that is weird or abnormal
let me uh
[ __ ] with you
but uh yeah
[Music]
other than that no problems from the
police
really a great place to stay another
place i would stay is rendon
i forget what it's specifically called
edward rendon park
that's right by the river too
great park to sleep in great park to
stay in
um
more rock
let me try to trade sheep in for brick
um but uh that's a great part it's a
park
it's very quiet very nice
good place to sleep
should i wait
damn i can't believe i got [ __ ] on
that seven
okay i'll do that
oh [ __ ]
i don't even need that
okay i'm just gonna go here and get a
development card
and a robber whatever if you know how to
play katan then
this might be fun
so the robber lets you move the robber
um
the number gets rolled these this is the
die and then you pick it up and then if
you have a thing on there you can do it
this is what it takes to build a road
and you need two roads
and then you can build a settlement you
can turn a settlement into a city this
is how much that costs you can trade
with people and this is how much
development card is it's like a
chance card in monopoly
whatever
who gives a [ __ ] it's all about me
me me me
look at me
it's me
um
those are the two places i stayed and
then like on the street anywhere i would
stay um
that was my number two love your comedy
boy first time seeing you stream lol
what are we looking at hi
it's a little board game called katan
um if you become a subscriber you can
become a catanimal
uh
you try not to be a katan virgin
what the hell is this
just delete that
via capture device
um
and what that is
trying to click on my face
there we go
it's my turn
oh [ __ ] this [ __ ]
who put that robber on me
ninja fro
blue is [ __ ] me why are you [ __ ]
me i'm already [ __ ] dude
little [ __ ] [ __ ] you
and then i roll
i get that
useless
but yeah blue and i have a little thing
going on
blue put that on me and then i think he
oh [ __ ]
he rolled a 7-2 well that was useless
stole i stole from ninja fro
oh he's still from aliber
oops
it's still from ninja fro so he got
[ __ ] twice by a robber
i got [ __ ] by having my spot blocked
sorry blue you actually weren't that
much of an [ __ ] watch me get seven
right now
if the seven is rolled then you have to
give up half your cards
um
it's a board game you're trying to get
10 points cities are worth two points
settlements are worth one
oh thank god
okay let me try to get a [ __ ]
thing right now
who wants anything
please
that's how he works
oh god red is trying to be a little
slimy [ __ ]
just pester them bother them until they
give me what i want
uh i can't do two of these i can do two
of these
for this
i can do one of these
let's see how many permutations i can
get to
that might not be a bad move
actually red
alright i'll do it
[ __ ] i'm getting [ __ ] this
game
i'm glad we could all tune in and watch
me get [ __ ]
wow wow again uh what is this game
katana celeriskatan it's katana pleb
thanks nerds hi this is a fortnight
you're so welcome cheers geek
i love eating my fortnite burger while i
vape
you're my second favorite hans after
hounds gruber those guys an enemy
uh just joined tony play this too no i
tried to play this game while i was at
an arena but
i really couldn't oh ninja fro oh thank
god he didn't steal from me
he stole from the real threat
red
um and it didn't really work out tony
was like come on let's go walk around
and so i just left the game
walk running and people got mad at me
because i was afk bro though only a
massive spike of energy due to steroid
has me awake at this hour that's cool
man where do you get steroids i would
love to do steroids
um i would do it right so that i don't
get the bad consequences but you know
hopefully there's
awesome things and steroids
visited park and mohan in his van and it
turned out to be right
next door to the institute of virology
um
yeah i mean
i guess i'm a dirty little boy
who else here is eating coconut shrimp
at 3am see that's the thing is like
not a lot of us are awake at this hour
and now we can all congregate
and
visit
we can create coalitions
and
figure our [ __ ] out i'm gonna get one of
these
this is gonna be my jam
is these little [ __ ]
robbers
thieves and i'm going to control the
robber even though a lot of sevens have
been rolled
red is winning
with five blue is that five but two of
them two of them points or longest road
if you get a longest road you get two
points
let me move my
head
so if you get two of these it's longest
road so
it's a thing
but these don't accrue resources so
it's not as valuable as his five points
which are all resource accruing
[ __ ]
um
but yeah
i um what was i talking about
that's the missing link in hansel just
some good old-fashioned steroids
i mean what's so bad about steroids the
only bad thing is if you do it wrong
uh but if you do it right you become
awesome and better and cooler and be
able to [ __ ] your friend's girlfriend
that's a
joke from a comedian
but
joey something from la very funny guy
that i just
lifted
uh i live in akrodor you buy them from
guys on facebook
i don't know if i want ecuadorian
steroids no offense to ecuador but
not really known for their health care
system
for swedish steroids i'd be like oh yeah
or the toity i would love some steroids
give me some steroids
semen has the same effect as steroids
only half as potent though you need a
double dose this guy's trying to make me
suck his dick
that's hot
i'm glad someone's not interested in me
that they want to rape me
was there some roast battle between hans
and berm
big red machine i'm guessing let me
[ __ ]
do this little maneuver cover this
little spot up for red
and let's see what i get ooh
useless
next
seven
if you roll a seven you have to give up
half your cards and you get to move the
robber but here's the thing
the [ __ ] robber
i just moved it i've spent a lot of
money to buy this [ __ ] robber
and then the next turn someone moves it
it was completely useless
he stole from blue blocked my rock which
might have been valuable if i get
another 11 i can build a city
but uh
you're walking with the youtube stuff
hi oh you love how i'm rocking with the
youtube stuff i mean
i don't really like the company
per se but it does provide a convenient
thing that everyone has
the thing i don't like about youtube is
that it's oh you [ __ ]
five was rolled and i wasn't there to
take advantage of it
everyone has whatever but you know i
hate youtube that it's a monopoly and
that no one can [ __ ]
do [ __ ] without
youtube's approval and they just have
too much power and i want there to be
less power in youtube
i trust hans more than my neighbor
thanks man
i trust you too
nine
interesting um
yeah i wish things were like the old
internet where things were more loose
and awesome and cool
um
yeah i don't like supporting it i wish
there was more options in the world
should i do this
then i just need wheat
let me do it orange orange is losing
like me
orange is not a
threat three rocks
one wheat i need another wood or a wheat
hey look at him he's coming up in the
world
oh god
i've got another rock
i don't need this [ __ ]
give me a [ __ ] wheat
come on orange don't be a [ __ ]
come on
i need this
i don't even know how much i need this
right now
blue
there we go blue
blue's finally paying off for me
now i can build a city
i'm probably gonna lose but
it's fun for me to play
this is such a low dopamine drip
of fun
you really have to get into it i guess
but hopefully i'll win
joe rogan died
oh my god people are trying to start
that rumor just one guy's trying to
start it
i try sounds more than limewire
uh what do you think of brendan schaab i
think he's higher than me on the totem
pole
i think uh
he's uh very accomplished at what he
does i mean i think he's very successful
at what he does
i think that he is a very
maligned man people seem to
misunderstand him or don't respect him
for whatever reason
orange you know what to do [ __ ] over
blue not me [ __ ] over blue and red right
here
or here put him over right here
um but uh yeah i mean i think he's a
very honest authentic dude trying to do
his best and people just [ __ ] all over
him and i think that's very rude um but
i think that we are living in a world
where there's a lot of uh anxiety and
stress and trauma and it makes sense for
us to attack people and
inflict pain upon others because pain
was inflicted on us so if
that's what happens with me
then uh why shouldn't this person who
they is more deserving of it
be uh
in pain
but i think he's like a simple i mean
he's like a jockey
uh you know
you know bro dude and he's not uh
the best at uh
coming up with
philosophy i mean not philosophy but
like theoretical physics like his brain
is works in a way that
is easy to make fun of
and so
people do and i wish we lived in a world
where people were less vicious
and whatever so that
people like uh brandon schaub would be
able to flirt oh my god
did someone steal from me they used
monopoly to get three rocks
pathetic
see the thing about monopoly cards is i
look at these question marks
and if there's two question marks it
means there's not a lot of [ __ ] oh my
god
orange got so many [ __ ]
oh boy
well at least i'm podcasting while i'm
losing i'm multitasking
uh randomly stumble across this
livestream and of course dude is playing
mahjong
dude
that is offensive
this is not mahjong that is a chinese
game that's a game those filthy [ __ ]
chinks play
who i hate
those
coronavirus starting
you know little red book
titan
little [ __ ] little shits play oh my
god red just [ __ ] me
no i love chinese people they have a
very rich deep culture
um but yeah this isn't mahjong um
it's a good game i wonder if i could get
cancelled for saying [ __ ]
i would love to
i think that'd be hilarious
um
because i'm asian they're like oh my god
he's a [ __ ]
like obviously
i'm joking but
yeah i mean um the mob is somewhat
unruly but i think that uh
some people deserve to get cancelled
and i think it's good that uh there's
like a higher standard of uh behavior
now like we have to be on our p's and
q's
i think that's uh
that's good
i think it's
that we should uh
try to excel in our speech
and that's what uh
having people
all shout out what they hate at the same
time does
obviously they're horribly
misguided sometimes
um
but i think uh
some degree of
uh
public protestation pro protestation is
necessary
dude i'm gonna win
this guy's a seven points
i got four but
it's going to happen
um i will give you wheat
but uh yeah
oh god
would you rather fight brendan schaub or
amy oh i like how you spelled amy in the
weirdest way
oh thank god i didn't get sevened
and so the good lord works
i'm gonna lose this game
let's buy devi
oh
what the hell
okay
okay i'm done
all i need is a brick
and then i can build a settlement here
and lose
like a man
um but
yeah brendan schaub is a giant [ __ ]
man
if you see him wrestling with
uh brian brian callan
you can see how huge he is and how much
of a difference that makes in a fight
i'm 32 years old i played this game
i heard playing this game gives you
herpes i think kissing strippers gives
you herpes so if i'm gonna do this
yeah this isn't mahjong that game is a
very
it's like war it's like 52 card pickup
it's very primitive
i actually have no idea how to play
um
but yeah i mean any game is a game
any game you can get into
this requires a lot of setup that's why
i like the digital form better
because you can
[Music]
you can set it up in an instant
um
where's the longest road he has the
longest road is five so i can get
eight points and then i need two more
and i might win so that's my strat
i wish i got this
i could have [ __ ] over red
but
you know
i would have to build two roads to build
a settlement
no matter where it is
but
yeah i mean
brennan shop is a big guy my parents
should have named me hans instead of
john all hail hans
okay who need
dmt when you can stay up all night and
play katan
better yet watch history
yeah i mean
i don't know how healthy this is
but you know i would rather be doing
this than
living my life in oblivion
at least i got to [ __ ] do whatever
karma for cutting black off at start
yeah
i'm black
um
yeah he cut me the [ __ ] off he really
[ __ ] me
a chat here i've gotten to a couple
flame wars i'm very bad at keeping my
emotions in check
uh saw you
insta on a private jet with tony rohan
rogan
he's obviously on his phone because my
on my phone rogan autocorrects to rohan
said what is your is your dad finally
proud i haven't told my dad yet can you
give us a four hour explanation how to
play this game we need more
comedy shows here in hawaii it's so dry
yeah i mean it's hard to get anything
out there
um
i don't have a brick yet oh i don't have
a prank i'm so sad
should i try to get longest road i won't
even get it if i try
yeah i'm just gonna
nice red sevened himself
um
yeah i mean it's a sign of success and
it is success to be able to do a big
show like that and to get the approval
of one of the best biggest comedians in
the world
it is success
um
[Music]
i feel successful
um but yeah i um
i think it's a cool thing to do i love
the private jet
got on there
it was like a little
private jet
a little seat
roll around lay down like i wonder how
much of uh being in a
uh being tired from a flight has to do
with
um
being cramped and being able unable to
move and being stuck in a seat the whole
time
um
[Music]
i think that is
like maybe you would get the same amount
of tiredness if you were stuck in a
small little seat for four hours
so it was good to have like a nice open
area to walk around to roam around to
jerk off
didn't jerk off in the bathroom didn't
even go to the bathroom it was only a
two-hour flight but ate a steak on there
um
[Music]
you know
it was a good time
uh it was a good way to travel
joe rogan was like
a lot of people pretend like they're
bawling but this is actual balling
i thought that was an awesome thing to
say
um
yeah i mean
i uh
i think that uh
it was a fun time
the fun time was had
um
and uh one of the most successful men
in the world
what the [ __ ]
why did i get another wheat well it
works out i guess
oh should i buy a dev card
yeah njfro might buy a dev card
and [ __ ] me
but i need to do this
sorry
i'll get one next turn
whatever
um
but i flew on the uh
private jet landed
then went
into the hotel 30 minutes away
chilled had a good time relaxed
um
explored my body
and then i
went to
the stadium arena for the weigh-ins
watched everyone
ceremoniously weigh in i don't
understand the point of that
it's just
well just call it a face-off it's called
the face-offs but they have to pretend
to weigh in
everyone is weighing in right now
[Music]
um oh i forgot i have the rock part i
wonder if i could have used that i
probably could have used that
[ __ ]
anyways
whatever
oh i bought a death card
if it's the largest army
we need to help red get the longest road
oh but then he'll oh no he'll only have
nine points then
then i have to get i just don't want
ninja fro to fro 98 to win i should have
got the def card
whatever
i'm just trying to lose i'm just trying
to make this guy lose
um
trying to help red get longest
road
um
i would love a dev card but i don't
think i can
i just use this now
i can't get longest road anyways
i need something
then i can get a dev card
come on please red okay thank you red
no one wants this
but uh yeah i got to the hotel
when i was at the hotel
he's gonna make me wait for sheep what
the [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay well if he doesn't have
largest army on the next turn
oh red is computerized he left he done
left the game
well i'm the only one with 12.
this guy is not even [ __ ] here
red is computerized
is he having
a night
oh he doesn't have a knight
what a [ __ ] loser
okay well i'll get the knight next time
i don't wonder what he has i wonder if
that's a uh
a victory point
okay let's get this [ __ ] off of
me largest army i have seven points now
that's pretty impressive
uh let me cover up blue because i don't
like blue
what's the best spot this is six dots
for him this is nine dots
uh
yeah this is what i'm going for
rock
i might win
eight
sheepies
and then a little sheepy
red i like red i'd rather have redwind
i'd rather have me win but
whatever he's a computer
he's a computer now
oh so what else is going on
i know how babies are made did you get
did you do any hijacking
what the [ __ ]
hijacking is that where you're jacking
off while you're high or in the air i
ended up in the er after it says our
friendship
got aggravated what else games you play
shawn likes kyle's you said teet
never said wayne's it's a t to see who
can get closest to death before the
fight yeah weigh-ins are [ __ ]
test teat it's 4am we're not gonna
we're not doing grammar police at this
hour hans you should play runescape
i can't believe i have eight points
that happened out of nowhere
what am i gonna use brick for
i could try to get longest road but it's
so hard one two
three four seven
eight
nine ten
i guess so
but unless i get more numbers really
having two more bricks isn't gonna help
come on you [ __ ]
someone needs to take a longest road
from this [ __ ]
jesus christ no one's gonna help you win
[ __ ]
i hope you get sevened
come on [ __ ] over blue please okay
that's fine
oh my god they're all both computer
computers
god damn everyone's so close
jesus
uh-oh
oh my god
as long as blue doesn't win
i'm gonna [ __ ] over blue again
seven dim [ __ ] took your card and got
you seven so that's five cards i made
him lose
and let's see
let's [ __ ] over him once again
that's four points
what a dick
that guy is
i really don't know how i'm gonna win
i could try to do this
ring road six seven eight nine ten as
long as orange doesn't [ __ ] with me
but he's already at ten i would need to
beat him and now i can't beat him
whoa
that was a lot
i can't believe i'm gonna win all right
i might win
oh my god no one is gonna trade with you
relax bro
holy [ __ ]
i got nine points next turn
i hope i got another sheep suck oh
god damn
orange one blue lost blue got second
whatever
tough game for me
pollution in a [ __ ] with me i really
[ __ ] him over
um but yeah i'm having a good time i
thought you meant it was a treat to see
who you get to closest to death before
the fight
are we watching future senate hearing
committees tape on what happens to
people in a world without bullying
uh in a world that has so
so you're saying because i'm a nerd and
i'm doing such a dorky stupid little
thing that
this is the kind of world that will
happen without bullying
um
yeah i don't know
eating
and that's the spot i chose
i might go here this is seven eight dots
i could go here five dots i could go
here four dots at a rock port
you go here
five dots and a wood port so this is
seven eight or eight dots really worth
it
is this spot gonna be taken by someone
else i say
nay i'm gonna go for a port
now i wait
forever while [ __ ] happens that i don't
care about
so i'm having a good time
um
i think weight cutting is stupid
we should not have weight cutting
not we they
they should not have weight cutting they
should just be like we're gonna weigh
you right before the fight and then the
argument against that
is that
fights might get cancelled well people
miss wait all the time anyways and the
fights don't get canceled they just
fight above the weight
and
you know that sucks you know
and then people are gonna cheat
just to win
so i think there should be a harsher
penalty for missing weight
maybe you have to fight with one arm
tied behind your back
but that's the thing with fighting is
like if someone has that kind of
advantage
then
you could get seriously hurt
and someone could die or something
yeah see if i built it right there he
would have i would have been [ __ ]
right there
um because red did a little little
whatever
now he can't [ __ ] me
so
i say
way people like usada testing if you do
use soda testing and you test people for
steroids you show up at their house at
2am and make them piss in a cup for you
do the same while you're doing that make
them step on a scale weigh them and then
show that to your opponent be like okay
this is what he's wearing right now what
do you want to do
and then
get rid of weight cutting it's horrible
for your brain to dehydrate it
and so if you are unfamiliar weight
cutting is a practice uh
popularized in
american collegiate and high school
wrestling
really is
a thing that
they decided to do legalized cheating
is uh
where they would
lose a lot of weight before a match a
wrestle bout a little skit of wrestling
they would lose a bunch of weight
right before
uh lose a weight the weigh-in 135 pounds
then
gain all that weight back under 45
pounds
and then they would have a 10 pound
advantage over someone who didn't cut
weight but then everyone started cutting
weight
so then everyone was doing this
ritualistic self-torture
immolation
uh sacrifice to the gods and
you know whatever
uh penance
uh for having a body
and it's it's just a wash it was like
people were
canceling it out so like everyone had to
do this now because everyone
was doing it so it's like the lowest
common denominator like one person
starts cheating and now everyone has to
cheat
um
it's very
very bad thing to do in my opinion
uh so yeah i mean
and the way the best way to lose a bunch
of weight
rapidly and then gain it back is to
lose water water
oh you [ __ ]
water is very heavy
and uh
relatively easily
uh
lost
and then you have kids doing this in
high school and they are shorter than
their brothers and sisters
because they [ __ ] were deprived of
water while they were in puberty to
wrestle
and it's
it's a really really not good thing to
do and
we should spend as much work and effort
and and energy goes into cutting weight
we should use that
and instead of
using that energy to lose weight water
weight and cut weight you should use
that to enforce
uh weight
requirements on fights whey people
all the time
you know test their hydration level you
can't weigh in dehydrated
uh
but like yeah i mean
these people don't want to change
there's nothing that they want to change
they're dinosaurs they want things to
remain exactly the same
[Music]
they they want that because
they don't know what is good to change
and what's bad to change
uh
what they know is that they are getting
more money than they deserve at the top
and
they don't know what is the cause of
that or what's you know
whatever
like
we're [ __ ] over the fighters and
now we have to keep things the same even
though it doesn't make any sense because
if we start changing things because it
doesn't make any sense well then a lot
of different [ __ ] has to change because
it doesn't make any sense
and they don't want to start that
process
of changing things
because we thought about it and it
didn't make any sense
because
that's gonna be
a very difficult
thing
to explain why
then that these people get so much money
and the fighters get so little so it's
just like a
system built upon
[Music]
preservation
preservation and conservation
conservative conservativeness
is a quality that is select that is
uh you know emphasized and uh
required or uh
and emphasized and you know
uh
you know like focused on because that is
what their economic system of making a
lot of money is based on
so i mean if they were
open-minded and they were like
trying to you know change things that
don't make sense then they would create
a better
better world
oh yeah
who is he talking about
talking to
where you play this katan
colonist.io
make them do a sumo match at face off to
balance things out
or how do you play this
make them do a super match i face off to
balance things out okay i say make sure
everyone is hydrated at wins and have
like a three pound window higher or
lower that they have to meet
anything but what we're doing now it's
just
so ridiculous that this is what we're
choosing deciding to do
to a sport that we love
as fans
um
[Music]
and we would have a higher quality
product
if we
made people
be nice
nice and healthy before a fight
we are the ones that are suffering or we
are one of the ones that are suffering
and it does not have to be this way
we can live in a better world we don't
need to just
preserve things the way they are
because that's how things are
we can change things that are broken and
wrong
and in fact we have a moral obligation
to do so
um but
yeah i mean i just think that the whole
system is built on preserving
uh the way things are because the way
things are is
um
making certain people a lot of money
it's all about money
but yeah i mean i uh
i don't think that's a good way to run
things
um but uh you know
it's good that people have the fire and
the desire to
[ __ ]
create
a product like the ufc and just i need
it i need to make it mine and take over
everything
that helps for a bit
anyways do you slow down
sit down and do you sit down and write
your jokes or do you come up with them
while
open micing both all
always
in all
forms i write sit down and write i think
of jokes while i am at open mics i think
a joke so i'm taking a [ __ ] or in the
shower or
fingering my [ __ ]
i do all of it any any any way to come
up with jokes if you want to come up
with jokes first have a
raging burning desire to write jokes and
then you will find whatever way
if you don't really want to if you just
sort of kind of want to write jokes
you're going to be like well um excuse
me sir how do you write jokes because i
kind of want to just kind of know
because i just want to write jokes
then you're going to ask for other
people to help you
and you're not going to try to figure it
out and
brunt brute force your way into writing
jokes
um
i try to squeeze a joke out of anything
and everything i can
and uh if you do that long enough then
maybe you'll write some good jokes
um
i played this guy before
oh my god
i don't think my win percentage is very
good right now 28.57
hey but i'm learning right
um i enjoy jokes i try to write jokes
everywhere
i try to write jokes
in every situation i can
um
[Music]
i think that
you know
if you want to write jokes then you'll
find a way to write jokes
just write down everything that comes in
your head write down things that don't
even come in your head that are just
somewhere else just put them
grab them from the air and find a way to
make it work
um
but
i
i think that
writing jokes is
a beautiful process
and once you write down every idea you
have then you can pin pic pick and
choose what you want to say
and figure it out
and
have a great joke writing experience
i mean it's beautiful to look at life
and try to find humor and joy in it and
try to find out what
is uh what is it that
piques your interest and what you think
other people like and
what is awesome to talk about etcetera
etcetera
yeah i mean write jokes i think everyone
should write jokes but maybe that's just
because i'm biased
should i should i should i oh [ __ ]
oh i don't want to trade with khan but
noam chumsky did anyways so
oh my god this guy's though so thirsty
for this it makes me not want to give it
to oh my god they're trading with each
other these [ __ ]
built the city
come on [ __ ] over red you've helped him
out too much
um
yeah i mean if you want to write jokes
really really want to write jokes and
then you'll write a joke
through whatever means necessary
oh why did you steal from me i guess i'm
winning with everyone else
[ __ ]
it's gonna be hard to get brick now dude
this guy's building so many [ __ ]
roads
oh this blue greens turn
oh you [ __ ]
i'm done i don't want any more of this
um
yeah i mean if you only write jokes
through open mics then you're not going
to come up with the jokes that you would
have
writing
so
you're not an open mic for you know 18
hours a day
so those 18 hours are prime joke writing
time that you are not going to have
i'm going to trade with them
because my
[ __ ] is blocked right now
i got wood here
we known as we didn't relax
um yeah i mean
so if you're if you're just letting that
time go to waste
then you're letting that time go to
waste
so
if someone can write jokes for 18 hours
and you can only write jokes for six
hours guess who's going to write more
jokes only reason why you wouldn't write
jokes sitting down and writing is if it
hurts you
writing jokes at open mics
um
and
i don't think that it does
if it does then you should find a way
where sitting down and writing doesn't
hurt your open mic
type of thing
jesus does no one have anything that
they want
for wheat no one has wheat i don't think
um
but yeah i mean
it's just more time that you have
writing
and i think it's important to also write
uh on stage and not tell yourself oh i'm
not a i'm not one of those people that
are funny in the moment or is has
strokes of brilliance when it matters
okay for some reason i wanted this
uh 9 12 this is definitely the one i
want
to emphasize
oh
um but yeah i mean i think it's
just foolish to be like oh i only write
jokes on stage i mean i think a lot of
funny comedians do that a lot of
comedians write through
um
a lot of convenience right through
um
oh my god this is so painful
a lot of communities right through uh
just on stage like bill burr but i think
that if you can learn how to write
jokes while you're not
uh
on stage then
the world is your oyster
and also writing is just a very
therapeutic process
and some people are not writers some
people are not book readers
and um
so like maybe it's not your style maybe
you're more conversational but i think
there's a very therapeutic thing about
sitting down and just thinking on
paper and something concrete
and seeing your thoughts in physical
form so you can look at it and judge it
and try to improve it
um
but
i think that it's not necessary it's
helpful you know it's helpful to write
um
blue did i trade with blue i traded with
haley
yeah i tried it with blue
um blue i'm fine with helping because
he's only got two points
um but yeah i think that uh writing is a
very very beautiful thing a lot of
people fall in love with it
don't forget don't let me forget i have
woodport and rockport
that ship might be useful
i want i want to build right here
that might be
nice if i can go all the way around
this [ __ ] really wants brick
i don't know if i can give it to you bro
i don't really need anything
um do i need it i'll trade on my turn
let's see what i get
don't hurt well sit and down i think
kill
bill
comes up with most of his ideas while
rambling on the podcast yeah that's what
i'm trying to do
is it working to write jokes you have to
dehydrate yourself
and cut minimum of 10 to 15 pounds and
get in a sauna for 48 hours
call back
call back music
7
my biggest enemy is green and red red
i shall
hear it
red and green
by placing over here
oh god which one i don't know i'm gonna
put it right here
take it from green
so he can't build anything
[Music]
let's take take
i don't need anything
oh yeah baby eight cards already
oh
you